ein glas kennst du das in die tria hat
man wahrscheinlich sind keine gläser gab
damals soziales werde wahrscheinlich
noch nicht mal erde oder luft schneidest
du das raus weil das kann echt sein dass
nachher bei die vordertür vor allem
viele afrikaner stehen und sagen hey das
stimmt nicht wir hatten leser recht und
auch luft und erde verkehrsrecht es hat
mich okay nein nein
ob ich das schon mal gesehen habe okay
du weißt was da drin ist papier ok mit
fragen richtig und weiß auch was für
fragen den scheiß fragen und sehen gute
freunde sehen ja bei diesem fall vier
scheiß fragen und drei gute fragen 43
verein power ein also ich darf das kann
es gucken du kannst leben zehn du kannst
dann nehme ich erst mal eine chance gibt
noch eine chance da machst dich über
integration ist es lustig findest du
deutsche politik scheiße ich finde
deutsche politik nicht scheiße okay aber
du greifst du ja schon ein bisschen an
dadurch will ihr also ich musste erst
mal im letzten jahr
politisch bin ich bin da habe ich so als
mal zur ruhe kam
überlegt über was sich im erziele und da
geht es halt darum um es geht um meine
herkunft ist darum dass leute mich
aufgrund meiner meines aussehens komisch
manchmal ok oder irgendwie eine
einstellung hatten die mich irritierte
und darüber erzähle ich und habe jetzt
so nach vor drei monaten festgestellt
dass es vielleicht doch manchmal
politisch ist ich selber bin kein
politiker kann mich auch nicht wirklich
gut aus ich lese immer die nachrichten
so hat mich interessiert das auch aber
ich finde deutsche politik nicht erst
dann scheiße wenn irgendwas scheiße in
bewusster gemacht hatte habe ich finde
generell deutsche politik nicht weiß
warum gibt es auch kein grund
naja da kann man da aber dann bin ich
wahrscheinlich zu wenig politiker oder
zu unwissend dass ich sagen kann dass
die deutsche politik reise ist
die deutsche bundeswehr an sagen die
politik der partei oder dieses
politikers gemacht hat ja gut also es
gibt oder acta ist scheiße sagen aber
ich bin wie gesagt schauspieler kein
politiker gut heißen scheiß frage heißt
meine fragen sage ich oder unverschämte
fragen werden immer wenn box bin ich
nicht will aber nicht abgebildet
ok zuweilen ebenfalls hättest du genauso
viel erfolg wenn du nicht ausländisch
aussehen würde eine politik komplett und
korrekte frage weiß ich nicht einmal ist
es außerdem wichtig bestimmt hat das
nicht also ich glaube es hat noch es hat
klar man videos das aussehen ist auf
jeden fall auch ein grund dafür aber
nicht nur gehören viele faktoren ich
weiß nicht ob so wäre aber es ist mit
ein grund auf jeden fall von vielen noch
mal ein drittel die roten haben
abarbeiten und dann kommen die guten
sachen schwierig weil die sind ja
harmlos aber schwierig harmlos es
könnten schlager sein
du spielst immer den dummen ausländer
sind die wirklich so dämlich wenn du
meine videos anschauen erstmal um einen
kanal gehen dann muss man alle videos
angucken ich habe acht verschiedene
touren
nicht alle dumm
für mich ist keine figur dumm sondern
diese nur die haben ihre eigene art zu
leben und ich finde aber gerade denen
die meisten wahrscheinlich sehr sehr
dumm empfinden er kann nicht alle fragen
beantworten
dann beantworten aber ich der fasziniert
mich extrem da er so die eier der stets
zu sich er hatte nur einer wird er steht
nicht zu sich so in der art das
fasziniert mich so für mich ist aber ist
das nicht erschrecken wenn ein mensch
der eigentlich von tuten und blasen
keine ahnung hat zu sich steht oder
überzeugt ist
weil er vertritt ja etwas und es geht
lassen es geht nicht darum so wie es
geht nicht darum dass irgend jemand dumm
ist und es geht darum ob er die
bereitschaft hat was zu lernen
das ist vollkommen natürlich aber die
also er will nicht was zuerst also ich
beziehe spitze dass er auch mal aber
natürlich hätte ich dann natürlich hätte
bestimmt aber es geht darum dass das es
gibt viele die manche dinge nicht wissen
so wie wir alle wissen nicht alles aber
hast du bock zu lernen oder nicht darum
geht es und gibt es leute die dich
unterstützen gibt es leute die dir
helfen was zu lernen darum geht so nicht
angekommen der iss und dumm
davon bin ich weiter langsam sagen sie
alle sind dumm machen wir was dafür dass
das das den leuten geholfen und ich
verstehe das gar nicht dieses es gibt so
viele schockiert ist jetzt nicht mehr
überhaupt nicht da ist was schockiere
das sind leute die etwas beurteilen aber
überhaupt keine grundlage dafür wirklich
traurig zum teil weil wir ja gut aber
das ist ein haus in der feindlichkeit
ausländerfeindlichkeit wir von der
anderen seite argumentiert dass leute
die haben sich 0 informiert oder sehr
wenig oder nicht nur die das haus
gebildet was ihnen in ihrer ablehnte
passt und dann darauf basiert die
ausländerfeindlichkeit das ist auch
nicht gut aber es hat auch einen grund
es kommt irgendwo her
die haben irgendeine vergangenheit
leider mit geschichte zu die ja schon
und manchmal einfach langeweile im dorf
und dann schließt man sich halt an was
weiß man also immer nur der ganz viele
dinge wo man einfach erledigen müsste
dann wäre es vielleicht nicht so also es
ist nicht so man muss einfach ein
bisschen aufräumen nicht auf wie nicht
auf freudige meisterin man muss einfach
ein bisschen gucken was kann man machen
das ist ein bisschen
das jeder so ein bisschen keine ahnung
das bekommt was was das was ihm gebührt
das dass er unterstützt wird und keine
ahnung mehr jedenfalls nicht gelangweilt
rumhängt und auf genau das ist dumm und
frech zu sagen wenn hier in deutschland
ist es ja so dass wenn man immer darüber
reden wie dumm alle sind dann traut sich
derjenige der vielleicht sein okay die
reden vielleicht über mich ich weiß
nicht wie traut sich auch gar nichts zu
sagen hey ich brauche hilfe
du trinkst ja immer was sie meint das
ist so immer muss anders da ran gehen ja
klar es gibt leute die die haben
studiert und die haben vielleicht die
möglichkeit gehabt andere auch die sich
hochgekämpft haben es gibt aber auch
leute die haben eine andere
vergangenheit die müssten vielleicht
kohle nach hause bringen und keine
ahnung also übrigens hier auch
interessante geschichten abschluss
hauptschulabschluss gemacht und trotzdem
von daten seine karriere und habe das
alles schritt für schritt gemacht aber
es ist deswegen weiß ich auch dass ist
nicht damit zu tun hat ob das dieses du
bist dumm nur wenn man was ich kann mir
alles an lesen
wir machen im moment nicht klar für mich
ist jemand nicht klug weil er weil er
mir erzählt wie mathematik funktion
mathematik oder oder keine ahnung was
zitiert was also ein buch was darin wird
das dann jeder kann sich dinge an lesen
für mich zeichnet sich intelligenz nicht
daran deswegen da müssen wir ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein da damit weil
man schichtet die leute auch einfach so
wir waren auf die frage aber wir haben
gut beantwortet du hast dir gut
beantwortet du spielst immer den dummen
ausländer sind die wirklich zugänglich
diesen
also ich glaube sie sollen ja
oberflächlich provozieren
aber was weiß man nicht
sie kommen einfach so
jetzt einfach mal um sich herum gucken
ja dann selber beurteilen er gut aber
der mensch ist halt das haben wir auch
in vielen interviews der möchte
natürlich vieles in schubladen
du spielst total verschiedene charaktere
weißt du manchmal selbst nicht mehr wer
du wirklich bist ja ok naja also jetzt
dann im letzten eineinhalb jahren habe
ich gemerkt dass ich beschäftige mich
jeden tag mit diesen figuren die ganze
zeit und immer wieder neue ideen und das
machen sie machen und zwischendurch
spielte ich dann auch ganz normale
schauspiel sein sohn hat mich irritiert
also es ist voll wichtig zur ruhe zu
kommen
merke ich einfach mal nichts mit
schulleiter man nichts mit figuren sind
einfach nur wieder teddy zu sein und
einfach mal ein bisschen tanken und es
voll wichtig die einfach die figuren
einfach mal links so einfach mal so zu
hause lassen das passiert mir manchmal
nicht mehr
moment bist du kannst jetzt gern auch
die grünen leisten da die sind natürlich
jetzt nicht so provozierend wir mussten
ihnen aber schwierig zu beantworten weil
die so auch pinseln sind wie toll bist
du eigentlich warum bist du so toll in
verschiedenen abwandlungen dass ein
riesiges selbstbewusstsein woher kommt
also manchmal ja manchmal so wie ich
habe manchmal bin ich bin ich total safe
und manchmal bringen mich dinge aus der
bahn
und ich frage mich warum aber so
entstehen auch viele sachen in maine
in meinen figuren so viele sachen sind
auch also ich pack da ganz viel von mir
auch eine sowohl als auch sehr
selbstbewusst bin ich würde ich mich
nicht bezeichnen ich weiß wohin ich will
und ich weiß was ich machen will aber
selbstbewusstsein das ich dahin stehe
und es wird interessant also ich bin
sowohl das auch jetzt tages abhängig
guckst du manchmal auf deine view seiner
videos und denkt sah das nicht so gut
gelaufen also ist das manchmal so
einfach versuchen das selbstbewusstsein
gerätes ist total also ich habe seinen
ganz eigenen rhythmus was das hochladen
vergeben hat zwei monate einen halb- und
ich finde es ganz gut wenn also wenn
dieser hype beginnt dann hast du auch
einen gewissen druck so und ich finde es
eigentlich ganz gut wenn es ein bisschen
ruhiger ist und ich mache sowieso in
erster linie ich bin ich was geil finden
dann lade ich das hoch und ich muss das
geil finden ok so und ich das heißt du
drehst viel mehr als wir sehen ja auf
jeden fall okay ich drehe und dann gucke
ich mir sagen wir nichts richtig geil
findet dann lade ich hoch und dann ich
muss überzeugt davon sein und wenn dann
am schluss klicks nicht so sind wie das
werden die auch nicht so ich glaube
jetzt hat sich auch gefestigt so jetzt
gibt es eine feste fangemeinde
aber es ist nicht mehr so diese 17
millionen klickt dingens irgendwie ja
was aber für mich ist dass ich bin wie
gesagt ich bin zufrieden und glücklich
wenn ich da wenn die wie gesagt wenn ich
dahinter stehen kann eine school und
wenn ich glaub ich hab alles beantworten
da darf man sich nicht verrückt machen
ich sagte ihr du schaffst es bei deinem
videos nicht zu lachen woher hast du
diese selbstbeherrschung und zwei dinge
einmal ist es einfach auf der
schauspielschule einfach du
konzentrierst dich auf das was du gerade
macht und wisse nicht was du
konzentrierst dich aber ich lache ich
nehme dieses wenig lachen muss bewusst
auch mit ok das heißt wenn es passiert
dann ganz so sein dasein nicht stoppt
unterbrechen teams mit auch eine figur
die duh kreiert er lacht und weint das
alles deswegen sowohl als auch
und das ist einfach konzentration müsste
ganze drin und wirklich was du was
willst du in dem moment erzählen als die
in dieser figur und dann siehst du dass
du durch meine lachen muss ein lasso
oder noch so in der figur das heißt
wahnsinnig viel wahnsinnig viel
professionalität was du hast was gelernt
und das kannst du 100 prozent umsetzen
ihr auch nicht immer so ich glaube
jedoch nicht dem video online gestellt
hast da wir zu sagen dass es also ich
steig dann auch nicht aus oder irgendwas
ist dann nehme ich das ich probiere
alles mitzunehmen
aber das kann ich auch nur weil ich
nicht skripte bei mir ist nichts getrübt
es kann auch dagegen es kann auch da
geht es kann überall hingehen ich hab
keine ahnung also ist es gibt keine
regeln also immer wieder spannend
überraschend und ist somit probiert
einzigartig ist ja echt nicht mehr nicht
probiert zumindest wie ein kick
zumindest im tv internet und sogar in
musical oder hast du dein talent das
müsste ja erstmal danke
ich liebe ich liebe zu tanzen ich liebe
zu spielen und ich liebe zu singen ich
mach das einfach über weiß liebe und und
mein ganzes leben seit ich klein bin
wenn irgendwas läuft wenn ihnen wirklich
und was im fernsehen lief oder wenn
musiker immer ich kann mich kann auch
nicht zwei sachen ich musste 100 prozent
da dabei sein und mich berührt das immer
total und ich glaube ich mache das mein
leben lang ich kann's nicht sein also
ist immer drin ich bin immer genauso
das freut mich sehr